this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skillshare
with the passing of ruth bader ginsburg
president trump was able to nominate and
appoint
his third supreme court justice amy
coney barrett this rankled many
democrats because the process took place
right before the 2020 election and under
covid circumstances
and the process included a covid super
spreader event at the white house but
they accused
president trump and senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell of rank hypocrisy
given that the republican senate refused
to hold a hearing on president obama's
pick for supreme court
merrick garland who was nominated 237
days before the 2016 election
i think it's safe to say there will not
be hearings or votes
i think it is also safe to say the next
president whoever that may be
is going to be the person who chooses
the next supreme court justice
this appointment of amy coney barrett to
the supreme court represents a large
shift in ideology on the court
and some democrats are calling for
retribution and this has caused some to
suggest that if president biden is able
to take control of the senate
he should engage in what's called court
packing if the democrats are able to
take georgia they could conceivably have
the votes to do it and the thing is
there's nothing special about the number
of justices on the supreme court we
didn't arrive at that number by divine
intervention
and it's not in the constitution so that
raises the question would it in fact be
legal to just simply expand
the supreme court if the democrats take
the senate can the party simply add
justices to the supreme court and then
fill those vacancies
what happened the last time a president
tried to pack the court and are there
any other limits that can be imposed on
the
members of the supreme court
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because the future of the
supreme court is
actually at stake you might recall that
two years ago marco rubio introduced a
constitutional amendment limiting the
supreme court to nine justices forever
he said there's nothing magical about
the number nine it's not inherently
right just because the number of seats
on the supreme court remains unchanged
since 1869 but there is something
inherently good and important about
preventing the further destabilization
of essential institutions
so is senator rubio correct that in
order to put limits on the supreme court
we'd actually need a constitutional
amendment well it depends on what kind
of limits you're talking about
and to understand the supreme court we
have to understand what's called the
judiciary act and of course the u.s
constitution the constitution mandates
that there be a chief justice article 1
section 3 clause 6 refers to a
chief justice who shall preside over the
impeachment trial of the president of
the united states but beyond that the
constitution is silent as to how many
justices
actually have to be on the court in
theory the constitution allows for just
two justices or 11
23 or 41. it doesn't say that there is
an optimal number and that's for
congress to decide article 3 section 1
of the constitution gives congress broad
discretion to establish the court system
quote
the judicial power of the united states
shall be vested in one supreme court and
in such inferior courts as the congress
may from time to time
ordain and establish now article 3 does
not provide how many justices will sit
on this
supreme court that was to be hashed out
politically by the earliest members of
congress and the president we typically
call these folks the founding fathers to
give them extra gravitas but at the end
of the day
they were just the earliest politicians
in this country they made some brilliant
decisions and some bone-headed ones and
that's what happens when you're
inventing a new country and the
judiciary act of 1789
established the first supreme court with
six justices the country was so small
that the
supreme court justices quote rode the
circuit hearing cases
in the regional circuit courts as well
as the cases before the supreme court
but in 1801 president john adams and a
lame duck federalist congress
passed the judiciary act of 1801 which
actually reduced the number of justices
on the court to five the goal was to
stop incoming president thomas
jefferson's court appointments
jefferson and his democratic republicans
quickly repealed the act putting the
court back to six justices but president
jefferson wasn't convinced that six was
the right number of justices for the
supreme court either and in 1807
jefferson and congress agreed to expand
the court adding a seventh justice when
congress added a seventh federal circuit
the idea being that as the country gets
bigger
you need more federal circuits and thus
more judges
are needed for the supreme court as well
and the next amendment to the judiciary
act in 1837
followed this same principle president
andrew jackson added two additional
justices after congress expanded the
number of federal circuit courts again
and the next big amendment to the
judiciary act was during the civil war
when congress created the 10th circuit
in 1863.
at this point the supreme court had 10
justices but in 1866
after the war congress passed
legislation to gradually reduce the
court to seven justices
this happened for two reasons first
republicans were redrawing the
geographical lines for the judicial
circuits going back down to nine
circuits so why not nine justices then
well because of the second point they
wanted to limit the influence of the
former confederate states there had been
a tradition of appointing a judge from
each circuit so each circuit had a
justice who could also hear circuit
cases
but this meant that between 1837 and
1862
five of the nine circuits comprised
exclusively slave states
so former confederates still had a
disproportionate impact on who was on
the supreme court
watching out for their interest but the
1866 act left only two circuits that
comprised of only former slave states
and only one that comprised only former
confederate states but as you learned
from history democrats fought
reconstruction tooth and nail and
three years later a new judiciary act
put the number back to nine justices the
judiciary act of 1869 said being enacted
by the senate and house of
representatives in the united states of
america and congress assembled that the
supreme court of the united states shall
here and after consist of the chief
justice of the united states
and eight associate justices any six of
whom shall constitute a quorum
and for the purposes of this act there
shall be appointed an additional
associate justice of said court so that
more or less brings us up to date with
the judiciary
in 2020. the number of supreme court
justices has remained at 9 since 1869.
and there are currently 12 regional
federal circuits organized from the 94
u.s judicial districts and there is a
13th circuit that's called the federal
circuit which has nationwide
jurisdiction over certain appeals based
on subject matter and obviously the us
has done away with a custom that there
should be one justice for each of the
judicial circuits otherwise we would
have four additional justices
but let's pause here and think back to
senator rubio's proposal that there
should be nine justices
on the supreme court forever why would
that be well for comparison purposes
consider other common law countries the
supreme court of the united kingdom has
12 members australia's highest court has
seven canada's has nine does this really
tell us anything about the fairness of
the institutions
we can of course make this a numbers
game but that's not really what this is
all about supreme court battles are all
about ideology
whose views are representative what are
the judicial philosophies of the
different justices and how does a judge
tend to rule about a particular issue as
much as both sides try to stand on
principle the court battles are mainly
about power and this is
just as true now as it historically has
been over time and for comparison's sake
the population of the u.s back in 1869
was almost 39 million people
the population in the us in 2010 was
over 300 million people you could argue
that a nation of 300 million people
needs a bigger supreme court to
adequately represent everyone's
interests
and many countries in europe ensure that
the courts have justices representing
all sides of the political spectrum so
given this logic the rising population
and the fact that there is no
requirement that the number of justices
on the supreme court stay
at nine and of course the tit-for-tat
nature of
uh adding more justices in retribution
for what happened to merrick garland
some people have argued that the next
democratic
president should simply add justices to
the supreme court something that's
called court packing now many of you
might be familiar with the term court
packing from your school days because
president biden won't be the first to
wrestle with the idea of court packing
and what most people remember is that
fdr tried to add six justices to the
supreme court but that's not quite the
whole story
in the midst of the great depression
roosevelt had proposed a number of laws
and regulations to stop the economic
meltdown
and to provide welfare to americans
generally these are referred to as
fdr's new deal but the supreme court
overturned a number of fdr's new deal
programs on the basis that they were
unconstitutional saying generally that
congress simply didn't have the power to
pass these kinds of economic regulations
because they didn't have the power under
the constitution's commerce clause and
fdr particularly disagreed with the
decision the supreme court made in 1935
and checked your poultry corp versus
united states
which struck down a part of the national
industrial recovery act
and given that the supreme court had
said these laws were unconstitutional
there was nothing that congress or the
president could do they
lacked the power it wasn't available
under the constitution
so in retaliation roosevelt suggested
expanding the membership of the supreme
court
the law would have added one justice to
the supreme court for every
justice over the age of 70 with a
maximum of six additional justices
the idea being that he would pack the
court with justices who agreed with his
ideology and his interpretation of the
constitution that would allow
congress and the president to pass the
new deal legislation but after public
outcry
the law to expand the supreme court did
not in fact pass but
interestingly the supreme court did take
a more favorable view of new deal
legislation and allowing much of it to
stand and
since that time it obviated the request
for more people to join the supreme
court
and ftr's attempt to pack the courts has
been portrayed as a power grab ever
since but there's an additional
dimension to fdr's plan that often
doesn't get recognition
it actually doesn't add necessarily six
justices it would have simply added one
justice for every sitting justice over
the age of 70
up to a maximum of six ensuring that you
would never fall below nine
even if the older judges died or retired
in part fdr's plan was addressing the
lifetime tenure of supreme court
judgeships
life terms for supreme court justices
has always been controversial
but in 1789 at the time of the first
constitutional convention
life expectancy was 34 years old by 2011
life expectancy was 78 years old is this
a problem for the supreme court well
that depends on who you ask at times
congress passed legislation to nudge
judges towards retirement
several republican congresses in the
1860s provided full salaries and
benefits to
all federal judges who retired this
worked and republicans were able to fill
several formerly democratic seats on the
judiciary in 1932 herbert hoover enacted
austerity measures during the depression
one of them was cutting supreme court
justice's retirement salaries in half
according to research by judge glock
herbert hoover's attorney general warned
that the law
meant justices will quote hang on like
grim death until the angel gabriel blows
the horn
he was of course correct once the bill
passed nobody wanted to retire
fdr recognized this and attempted to
restore their full retirement salaries
but the bill failed and that was
actually part of
fdr's court packing plan as well the
legislation would have restored the
justice's full pensions
judge glock's research on this matter
found records in fdr's library in the
papers of his attorney general homer
cummings
demonstrating the court expansion plan
was modeled on what republicans did in
the 1860s
and in 1937 congress did in fact restore
the full pensions for retiring justices
and one justice actually retired now
critics of court packing point out some
extremely obvious flaws with the idea
the first of which is that court packing
isn't really a permanent solution
since this isn't codified in the
constitution itself
if the norm of a nine justice supreme
court is violated
then effectively any time a political
party takes control of the house
senate and the presidency then they can
change the number of justices on the
supreme court and the
two parties can enter into a
never-ending cycle of one-upsmanship
where they simply
expand the court whenever it is
convenient for them and in fact
former harvard professor and legal
commentator lawrence tribe says
obviously partisan court expansion to
negate the votes of justices whose views
a party detest and whose legitimacy the
party doubts could trigger a tit-for-tat
spiral that would endanger
the supreme court's vital role in
stabilizing the national political and
legal system so not only could the
supreme court expand and expand any time
that a political party finds it
convenient to do so
but that very expansion might take away
some of the legitimacy that people
associate with the supreme court's
rulings on different things and remove
some of the independence that the
supreme court
is at least theoretically supposed to
have so apart from simply adding
justices to the supreme
court what else could be done to reform
it well some people are arguing for
ending lifetime
appointments this is constitutionally
suspect the constitution says that the
judges of the supreme court will
stay in times of good behavior which
generally has been interpreted as being
a lifetime appointment that the
judge gets to decide when he or she
retires and that
there's nothing that congress can do to
force someone to early retirement
or to set term limits for the justices
and there are many places in
federal service where you want lifetime
appointments to be free from any kind of
political
influence but some scholars suggest that
you can get around this by simply
rotating the judges through that
someone can be appointed to a term in
the supreme court and then relegated to
one of the federal circuits
after a certain number of years have
been served and there are pros and cons
to this approach
some argue that having a lifetime
appointment means that justices will be
completely free from political influence
others say that it simply creates an
incentive for politicians to appoint
extremely young judges who agree with
you ideologically
who will stay on the court for years and
years and years and then
the other side simply won't have an
opportunity to appoint somebody else
but as we saw since the fdr days a
lifetime appointment means that some of
the justices will simply
hold on forever until they actually
might pass away
in office this is one of those areas
that regardless of what the constitution
says there's not necessarily a right
answer in terms of
term limits for supreme court justices
in fact justice ginsburg supported
shorter terms for supreme court justices
the most popular suggestion is limiting
justices to 18-year terms this is a
reform that seems to have had
bipartisan support in the past but there
are some constitutional problems with it
neither congress nor the president can
fire judges or force them out of office
without cause however the constitution
provides that
justices shall hold their offices during
good behavior good behavior has been
interpreted as conferring lifetime
tenure on judges
and imposing term limits would probably
require a constitutional amendment
though some argue it's possible that you
could shuffle a supreme court justice
off of the supreme court
into one of the federal circuits thus
keeping them employed in the federal
system as
a judge just not on the supreme court
for
their life tenure but this also wouldn't
solve the politization
problem battles over nominees would
probably still be
fierce some argue for a bigger court and
a panel review system vanderbilt
professors tracy george and chris
guthrie proposed that
congress changed the court's
institutional design their idea is to
increase the size of the supreme court's
membership and remake it in the image of
the u.s court of appeals first they
suggest increasing the size so it's
approximately the same size as the
circuit courts which have around 13
judges per circuit
second they propose that the court
should hear almost all the cases in
panels rather than as a full court which
could at least double and perhaps even
triple the supreme court's
decision-making capacity
which means that the court could decide
even more cases panels would be randomly
selected
so we would not know in advance
precisely which judges would decide the
case and third
guthrie and george say that the court
should retain the authority to grant an
on-bonk review
in the small fraction of cases that call
for the court to speak as a full body
and this is effectively how the other
federal circuits operate all the time
theoretically the benefits of this
proposal include greater consistency and
clarity in the law
in addition to arguably less politicized
nomination processes
and still others argue for supreme court
reforms that acknowledge that it is in
fact a political
body some argue for what's called the
balanced bench approach a plan created
by law professors daniel epps and ganesh
satorumon
their plan in a nutshell starts with ten
supreme court justices
five would be affiliated with the
democratic party and five with the
republican party these ten justices
would then select five additional
justices chosen from the current circuit
or possibly district court judges these
five circuit court judges would need to
be selected unanimously by the
ten partisan judges and they'd need to
be chosen
two years in advance for one-year terms
and if the justices failed to agree on a
slate of additional colleagues
the supreme court would lack a quorum
and they could not hear any cases for
that year
the balanced bench plan rests on the
idea that the partisan-affiliated
justices would have to pick justices who
probably would never be appointed to the
supreme court because they have
views that aren't easily traceable to
party affiliations and
absences tarman believed that the
justices would select five people who
have a reputation for quote fairness
independence and centrism but of course
regardless whatever benefits this
approach would have
it's clearly unconstitutional so it
would require a constitutional amendment
to actually
implement but why let a silly little
thing like being
unconstitutional prevent it from being
adopted but there's no dispute that for
better or worse
the system currently is based largely on
luck some presidents might not get to
appoint a single supreme court justice
while others might appoint
three or four but whether there are nine
justices on the supreme court or 900
if you ever want to get to the supreme
court you've got to learn to write
really well
in fact all lawyers have to write really
well and the best place to learn
anything is on
skillshare which is why you should take
sabbah to hear skillshare class writing
authentic fiction
how to build a believable character so
ball walks you through her personal
process for crafting authentic and
believable characters it's packed with
exercises prompts and tried and true
techniques it's a class that will teach
you how to create real and nuanced
characters that feel like they could
walk right off the page or you could
take my friend thomas frank's class real
productivity how to build habits that
last
because lawyers have to be incredibly
productive thomas focuses on
strengthening your internal
self-discipline assisting that
self-discipline with smart external
systems
and improving those habits over time
with regular reflection skillshare as
i'm sure you know is one of the world's
largest online learning community is
that has tens of thousands of classes on
everything like illustration
business creative writing music and
productivity and the first 1000 legal
eagles will get a free trial of
skillshare premium when you click on the
link in the description
plus after the trial ends skillshare is
still way more affordable than most
online learning platforms out there with
plans starting at less than ten dollars
per month so just click on the link
below to get a free trial membership of
skillshare plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis do you think that
the supreme court should stay at nine
justices
or should it be expanded leave your
objections in the comments and check out
this playlist over here with all my
other real law reviews
talking about the crazy stuff that's
happening in the trump administration
covid related legal issues and all the
important legal issues of the day so
click on this playlist and i'll see you
in court